imagine you wake up one morning and
notice everything around you is just a
tiny bit different
maybe you're in the same house but
furniture is slightly out of place your
favorite coffee mug is there but it has
a crack you don't remember and you could
have sworn your coffee maker was black
but this one is chrome
and just as you think that you're going
crazy you feel a strange tingling
sensation and hear a buzzing in your
ears a flash of light the buzzing stops
and you feel dizzy as you regain your
balance you look around
everything seems back to normal the
coffee maker is black your mug is not
cracked so
what was that a dream your imagination
it seems so real are you just over tired
or are you going crazy or maybe you
somehow slipped through the multiverse
for a brief moment you squish lives with
yourself in an alternate reality there
are documented cases of this happening
to people all over the world this
happened to a man traveling through
tokyo airport when he presented his
passport the authorities were baffled
the passport was genuine the only
problem was the country that issued it
didn't exist
quantum mechanics sounds like science
fiction things happen at the quantum
level that we just don't understand for
instance we can measure the position of
an electron but where things get weird
is before you measure the position of
that electron it behaves like a wave and
this is proved by the double slit
experiment i won't go into that now but
we covered in detail in our episode
about simulation theory which is linked
below if you watch that video make sure
you've got a brain bucket handy
anyway you can think of the wave
function as the sum of all the positions
of an electron simultaneously
so it exists everywhere it exists
everywhere at the same time oh boy do we
have
i get a headache i know i know even
famous physicist john wheeler said if
you're not completely confused by
quantum mechanics you don't understand
it he was right about that as soon as
you measure that electron it locks in
that one unique position but many
scientists believe there are universes
that exist for every position of that
electron and in those infinite universes
there are infinite versions of you this
is called the many worlds theory every
time a quantum measurement is taken the
universe branches off into another
parallel universe since there are an
infinite number of these universes out
there somewhere is a reality where
dinosaurs didn't go extinct there's a
universe where americans lost the war
for independence even a universe where
you're a big movie star they're all out
there but nobody thought those realities
could interact with each other
until 2014 scientists proposed a theory
based off many worlds called many
interacting worlds this theory says that
not only do infinite parallel universes
exist but they can and do interact with
each other this might explain why lorena
garcia woke up one morning wearing
different pajamas she went to work and
someone else was in her office she
worked in the same building but now was
in a different department and worked for
a boss she didn't know and when she got
home her ex-boyfriend was there
but they broke up months ago
or in 1851 joseph warren was found
wandering around frankfurt germany when
authorities asked him where he was from
he said the country of laxaria when he
was shown a map he knew the geography of
the earth perfectly well but to him the
continents were named sacria aflar aslar
oslar and uplar
another incident happened in 1905 a man
was caught stealing a loaf of bread in
paris when he was captured by police he
spoke a language no one could recognize
they figured out he was saying he was
from lisbia thinking he meant lisbon
portuguese interpreters were brought in
they said they have no idea what
language he's speaking but it's
definitely not portuguese and that takes
us to the story about the man from turid
who somehow drifted out of his own
universe and into our own launching a
mystery that would last for almost 70
years
when you mention parallel universes
the eyes sort of roll up and you giggle
and you say to yourself ah this is just
silly this is nuts
however things have changed now the
paradigm has shifted the multiverse idea
once thought to be so crazy it only
belonged on evening night television
has now become the dominant theory in
cosmology it's unavoidable you cannot
avoid the theory of the multiverse in
1952 seven years after a brutal war with
the allies and subsequent occupation by
american forces japan was once again
free it shifted its economy from
military focus to industries like
technology and finance and this new
market created tremendous opportunities
and people from all over the world
poured into japan daily usually coming
through hanita airport in tokyo it was a
hot afternoon in july 1954 and the
airport was buzzing these were the days
before a full body scanner or something
remove your laptops tablets and place
them in their own dirty plastic tray
that's still wet from the last guy for
some reason right take off your belt
your shoes and remove any lotions creams
and gels and place your personal items
in another dirty plastic tray once you
step through our x-ray machine that may
or may not cause cancer we may decide to
put on plastic gloves and fondle you in
front of a group of strangers
this is what we in the tsa call the
cherry on top
you good
i've been wanting to get that off my
chest for a long time
travelers back then didn't have to deal
with all that nonsense but they still
had to present a passport to airport
security and customs agents a
businessman middle aged caucasian with
dark hair and a beard made his way to
the front of the line he handed over his
passport which was filled with stamps of
the countries he'd recently visited the
customs agent looked puzzled he glanced
up at the man back to the passport
up at the man again and asked his name
broderick gennansfer said the man date
of birth the man replied 11th of
september 88.
so far so good then the agent asked
country of birth the man replied very
casually i'm from torred
the customs agent had never heard of a
country called torred but there are 200
countries in the world and some of them
are smaller than even the smallest
states in the u.s so the agent called a
colleague over the second agent was also
confused he too had never heard of a
country called torrid neither did the
agent's supervisor then the customs
agent asked mr gennansfer do you think
you could show us on a map where torret
is now gin answer was getting annoyed
but what's he supposed to do so he says
of course and then he's taken to a
private room to prove to the officers
that he was telling the truth
[Applause]
and so the multiverse is not just some
invention out of the ether
it flows out of an application of
quantum mechanics to general relativity
we're not completely there yet with a
full solution
but it's why the idea is taken seriously
it's not just an invention
broderick genansfer the man from torred
was visibly upset now the officers
brought him a map of europe asked him to
point out tored and without hesitation
he pointed to a small country on the
border of france and spain now this made
sense to the customs officers because
even though jinnansfer was speaking
japanese he did have a french accent but
the problem wasn't his language it was
his country the officers told him that
he was pointing to the principality of
andorra and there's no such place as
torred janaz first started arguing he
said the kingdom of torrid is a thousand
years old and he'd never heard of
anything called andorra which he thought
sounded fake jennansfer then said he had
traveled through this very airport twice
this month and never had a problem he
had stamps in his passport to prove it
now this was easy enough to check the
customs agents confirmed that the stamps
were authentic but they still weren't
convinced of his story ginanford took
out his wallet to show the agents as a
business traveler he carried different
currencies with him the customs agents
examined the money he had currency from
japan and several european nations but
he also had money from torred
which seemed like real currency except
for the fact that there's no such place
he also had travelers checks
unfortunately for him the checks were
issued by a bank that didn't exist the
agents started to suspect ginanfur might
be up to no good maybe a criminal or a
spy they asked where he was staying
gennan's first gave them the number of
his hotel and assured the agents he had
been on the phone with them that morning
making his reservation they called the
hotel which was there but they had no
reservation under this man's name now
the hotel could have made a mistake so
jansfer instructed the agents to call
his office in tokyo surely this would
settle the matter they called the
company had no record of an employee
named broderick genansfer the man from
torred and the customs agents were
stunned they had no idea what to do then
the phone in the corner of the room rang
an agent answered listened for a moment
then turned to gennansfor and said sir
you're coming with us
the customs agents were stuck they had
never seen anything like this before but
they couldn't let the man go without
investigating they confiscated broderick
gennan's for his passport his money and
other documents they told him that he
wasn't being arrested but he was being
detained until this matter could be
cleared up he was put up in a hotel near
the airport for the night two armed
guards were stationed outside his door
at all times he was instructed that the
phone would only work to call room
service the evening passed without
incident ginance for complained of a
headache but he hoped a meal might make
him feel better he ordered room service
and settled in for the night the
following morning the customs agents
called ginance for his room but got no
answer the guards were instructed to
open the door when they entered the room
the man from torred was gone the room
was spotless the bed was made there was
no sign that anyone had eaten a meal or
that anyone had even been there the
guards were chewed out by their
supervisor for letting this man slip
away but they insisted that they did not
leave their post the windows didn't open
and the door was the only way in or out
aside from a hotel employee delivering
food nobody went in or came out of that
room all night
now back at the airport customs was
still investigating when they went to
retrieve janan's first documents even
though they were stored in a locked
security office they were gone the
passport wallet checkbook everything
vanished it's as if the man from torred
never existed and word of the
investigation quickly went up the chain
of command in the japanese government to
avoid embarrassment the story was
censored classified and everyone
involved was told to never speak of it
in the years since the man from taured
arrived and disappeared there have been
a lot of theories one was that he was an
intelligence agent working undercover
his passport and documents were fake to
ensure that the government he worked for
would never be revealed and this was the
1950s the cold war was gearing up and
spies were everywhere a highly trained
covert operative might be able to find a
way out of that hotel room without
alerting the guards but it doesn't
explain how his documents disappeared
from a secure room in the airport the
theory that's most popular is that the
man from torred was actually from an
alternative universe
somehow during his flight he crossed
over into this one nothing on the flight
changed that much that he noticed he was
just unaware that the country he was
from no longer existed and that night
when he was complaining of a headache it
could have been our two realities trying
to get back into sync and when they did
the man and his belongings went back to
the correct universe and maybe at the
very same time in the other universe a
businessman from andorra was having a
difficult day and maybe that man was
detained by security officers who
insisted there's no such place as
andorra and the country that man pointed
to on the map was actually the kingdom
of torrent a nation that had existed for
a thousand years
or maybe
[Music]
the man from torred is an urban legend
that's been around for a long time the
current version of the story the one
that you heard today goes back to 1981.
that year a book was published called
the directory of possibilities which was
a collection of stories strange events
and theories and in that book there was
one interesting passage and in 1954 a
passport check in japan is alleged to
have produced a man with papers issued
by the nation of torret the author got
this from a news article that goes back
to 1960. there was a man named john alan
zegrus who wanted to travel the world so
he invented a country a capital a
language and put all these on a passport
that he created himself and zegras
claimed to be working as an intelligence
agent for colonel nasser who was then
prime minister of egypt he said the
passport was issued at tommen rossett
the capital of tuareg nataman rasat is a
real city in algeria but tuareg is a
country he made up still he traveled all
over the middle east using this story
not only did countries accept his
tuiretian passport but because he said
he worked for the egyptian prime
minister they rolled out the red carpet
for him but zegras ran into a snag when
he got to tokyo they didn't buy any of
it he was arrested for having a forged
passport and possessing fake checks the
country he used on that passport wasn't
tuared he said he was from nagusi habisi
esprit which doesn't mean anything well
at least that one has a little pizzazz
it does but zegra stuck to his story the
whole time even while he was in a
japanese courtroom he said he was an
intelligence agent working for egypt
under the direction of the united states
that story didn't pan out and he was
sentenced to a year in prison and that's
how the legend of the man from torad got
started and like every good urban legend
there's some truth to it zagrus was a
real person
multiple universes may exist and
sometimes they could interact the only
real mystery left is
what happened to john allen zegras after
he got out of prison nobody's been able
to track him down he seems to have
disappeared once again
who knows maybe he went back to his own
universe after all
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor and
like subscribe comment share that stuff
really helps out a small channel and
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you